Islamic ingredients of Peace how you
guys doing when you look at the Muslim
Community now I want to start off with
saying Patrick Ben David has come a long
way regarding Muslims and Islam and we
commend him for that Muslims have the
lowest percentage of divorces lowest
percentage of divorces how do you feel
about abortion how they feel about lgbtq
all of that stuff Muslims have a
conservative belief recently I think
Andrew Tate was one of the first one of
the first Muslims to be on his show you
can't say that Islam isn't the most
successful religion on Earth it's the
most successful in regards to opposing
evil it's the most successful in regards
to opposing its differing viewpoints
it's the most successful in regards to
having people act within the limits and
the confines of what it finds to be
moral and good to God it's the most
adhered to and now we see him going in a
great Direction trying to get people to
think more about what Muslims and
Christians have in common and I think
he's going in the right direction and
what if Muslims and Christians come
together and say look let's set aside
Prophet Muhammad and Jesus we know what
you believe in we know what we believe
in but listen when comes under these
issues with family let's unite one key
point I'm going to get into right off
the bat is that we as Muslims we don't
have to put Jesus to decide you got to
know that because as Muslims it's an
Article of Faith to believe and love
Jesus we love Jesus do you understand
that we believe that he was my one of
the mightiest Messengers sent by God
Almighty we believe in his miraculous
birth we believe he was the Messiah we
believe that he did many wondrous
Miracles by the permission of God
Almighty to prove that he was indeed a
messenger of God and If you deny Jesus
you say any disrespectful thing about
Jesus this can land you into the
Hellfire as a Muslim we believe this so
the same way we would go ahead and
defend Prophet Muhammad peace and
blesses be upon him as one of the Tate
Brothers says Tristan Tate the Muslim
world is a part of the world where you
could not walk around and freely insult
Jesus so I feel perfectly at home in the
middle so let's get into this episode of
what Muslims and Christians have in
common with Patrick um I'll say this I
would much rather work with a Muslim
parent Association than an lgbtq
organization this is good to see they're
acknowledged that many Christians are
starting to see the benefits that can
come from working together with Muslims
on these issues that are facing our
families our children
and us working together these two guys
two communities
imagine all of a sudden a liberal has to
defend a muslim with pure values they're
also saying we're saying the
contradictions with some politicians
unfortunately who claim to be Muslim but
are doing opposite to Islam you see Elon
Omar tap dance around this whenever she
gets asked questions about this trans
stuff
[Music]
I am so excited to be here with you all
to kick off this beautiful weekend and
to celebrate all of the diversity of the
lgbtq community happy Pride everyone let
me touch upon this thing Muslim
Americans having animosity to a
Christian Christians towards Islam
there's an understandable fear that
that American Muslims have animosity
towards American Christians and vice
versa this is generally this is not the
case this is not true except in cases
where you have unfairly Muslims have
been unfairly targeted discriminated
against unfairly bombed unjust Wars like
the weapons of mass destruction you guys
know about this and how many millions of
Muslims killed unjustly so under this
lie is a great documentary Dirty Wars
you can watch this so otherwise Muslims
live by this this verse from the Quran
is clearly saying that he does not
forbid you for dealing fairly and justly
with those who have not fought you
because your religion or driven you out
of your homes Muslims are 99 in
agreement why so so say why is there
that well the vision between the two so
one of it is is a is a unders is a
theological and I share some of this
right belief that radical Muslims want
to bring Sharia to the United States and
that's why you got to have a Muslim on
the program Patrick to go ahead and
discuss these things but I'm just asking
you a question what is Sharia do you
even know what a Sharia is how about if
I just give you a few things to think
about Moses Ten Commandments uh what do
you think about that you know has
mentioned over 200 plus times in the
actual Bible this is the Divine Law
God's law and what is God's law the
Sharia what did God's law come to do let
me just Define some things go over some
things it came to preserve life human
life it came to preserve the lineage of
the family uh your heart to came to
preserve your heart mind your intellect
your wealth your religion your
connection with your creator the pure
monotheism now after you get to know
these things and you get to know the
essence the foundations of Islam God's
law Sharia would you rather live by that
and most people when these things are
explained they usually agree with it
their innate nature agrees with these
would you rather to live with that or
with what he's talking about here what's
happening let's pretend you think that
Muslims want an authoritarian regime
you're already living under one you're
living under a trans authoritarian
regime and here's a group of people that
want to smash that regime wouldn't it be
nice to build a coalition so this is
interesting Patrick goes on to talk
about uh relaying a story that happened
with his Muslim friend it's nice that he
has actually I believe he has a Muslim
friend here but love him love his wife
Naveen good people
so he starts talking about Muslims
America Israel Republican Christians and
this guy is a hardcore conservative yeah
maybe more a hardcore conservative than
a Muslim and not saying something
because he is a Muslim and a proud one
okay let's stop right here let's look
this up what is a conservative it talks
about conservative let's look up a very
basic definition here I look it up it
says averse to change or innovation and
holding on to Traditional Values a verse
to change in what this is a very
important Point here that you
distinguish between religion innovation
in worldly matters technology etc etc or
then in religion no you cannot change
the original add to it it's perfect God
Almighty says this day have I perfected
your religious in the Quran and are
chosen for you what God Almighty I've
chosen for you Islam submission to the
will of God submission to the will of
God this is what Islam is you cannot add
to it delete it and what Traditional
Values are we talking about we talk
about Traditional Values of let's start
with Abraham for example he wasn't a Jew
or a Christian he was one who again
submitted his will to the will of God he
was morally upright holding on to those
Traditional Values yes we're for it
holding on to the traditional moral
values of Jesus's mother or Jesus the
way he prayed the way he treated his
neighbor the way his mother dressed the
moral the morality of herself how she
was a chaste woman holding on to those
Traditional Values absolutely 100 here
we'd say according to this definition
but we don't change the religion to suit
the time to suit men changing things so
you can go ahead and have all these
things that's going on for instance
selling out God selling out your
religion no this is what this is one of
the things that attracted Andrew to
people like Andrew Tate and others to
Islam that it's strict adherence to the
book to the Quran and the Sunnah as we
call it to the Divine Law not man man's
subjective desires no and this is a very
important thing here is that we would
say according to this we are more
conservative according to this
definition than the conservative holding
on to these Traditional Values of
goodness that God Almighty had revealed
and more Christian than the Christian
think about that one the way we go ahead
and greet just starting from that simple
things like this in the Bible it says
Jesus he would reap peace be with you
from holding on to uh the beard for
instance from the way Jesus now moving
along the way he fasted we fast the way
Jesus prayed and he fell on his face and
he prayed look it up it's in the Bible
Matthew 26 39 and he went a little
further and he fell on his face and
prayed find me another group of people
who is praying like Jesus prayed and
more importantly so who did he pray to
if you look at the fourth The Lord's
Prayer or father who are in heaven
Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done he's praying to the
almighty to the Creator this is the
submission to the will of God thy will
be done this is Islam so yes we are
holding on to the most conservative
values and also we would say even more
Christian than the Christian and he's
the kind that converts he's not a kind
that just talks about it so he's the
kind that converts and he converts
Christians here's interesting he talks
about he's the kind that converts
he's not the one who just just talks
about it he's pretty much he's pretty
much given Dao this is the invitation
that we just it's not our job to convert
a Muslim job is not to convert anybody
God Almighty is the one who guides the
hearts it just as I often say if you
care you share so it's us to give the
alternative
and to give the solution to many of the
world's problems and it's up to you if
you'd like it you accept it if you don't
you reject it that's all that this man
is also doing and a truth stands out
clear from error and when it comes it
makes sense it makes sense from the pure
monotheism to all of the other things
the rules and regulations that are there
for the preservation of the family
Society humanity and this is what the
Tao is what his friend is doing and
whoever you are brother the brother
who's Patrick Davis friend I'd like to
meet you I'd like to have you on whoever
can make the connection make it happen
he goes on to talk about the growing
number of people accepting Islam
especially women I think the number was
shown on how many Americans have
converted to Muslim the numbers like 20
000 Christians of which 75 are women
that have 25 percent are men this is
interesting he says converted to Muslims
small correction here not a big deal we
say converted or reverted to Islam and
every child is born on the pure fitra
this is what we say that every child all
of the creation from the baby in the
womb to the mountains to the birds to
the bees the Seven Seas everything has
come in complete submission to the
creator of the heavens and earth and
when that child grows up
everything now around him is a pushing
in this direction in that direction but
that child was to be left alone it would
grow up to go ahead and submit to one
and only one God if he was on an island
by himself if he was in the mountain
somewhere no religion came to him he
would be on the pure fitra that is he
would be a Muslim one who submits to the
will of God Almighty not to a statue not
to a stick to a stone nothing but the
creator of the heavens and earth and
just to give this definition even more
clarity if Jesus came back today and you
asked him what religion are you we
wouldn't expect him to say Christianity
because if he did then you'd ask him
what the sect of Christianity which uh
one Roman Catholic Anglican Presbyterian
Lutheran Jehovah Witness he would say my
religion is a total submission to the
will of God this is a lengthy definition
but in one word this is Islam of which
75 percent are women this by itself this
point this fact here this statistic
should go ahead and dispel that myth by
itself that Islam oppresses women
because why would women come to a way of
life a religion that oppresses them no
they are coming for True freedom and
they're finding that in Islam this is a
good part here where he acknowledges why
Muslims would be upset but but no no
you're right Christians West relax like
hey we got 800 military bases in the
world we're in everyone's freaking
business of course you're gonna piss
people off you want to know about
everyone's business everyone's divorced
leave my marriage alone of course you're
going to create enemies okay and what
are the things that we getting people to
think what are the things that we have
in common we can agree upon so we can
unite for the greater good now we have a
mutual understanding and agreement what
do we agree on family values and
principles why don't we unite here and
all the other stuff guess what Muslims
here he touches upon the statistics of
Muslims having more kids number one is
Muslims guess what Christians you ain't
having enough babies that's your problem
go compete have more babies these guys
are doing 2.9 4.9 you're doing 1.9 2.1
this goes back to family and Islam being
not allowing men to test drive women
fooling around we have What's called the
nicad this is Nika very simple look it
up two witnesses
the woman's rep and you get married no
excuses now
no excuses for zinna looked that up
fornication adultery no no no no and you
get right with God it's very
straightforward very simple and then he
talks about how Muslims are kicking gear
in this these are logical conversations
where you can't be like well I don't
want to compete against Muslims no
they're kicking your ass why are Muslims
angry I think there's a super simple
reason why most Muslim countries have
difficult or rather so angry is because
they don't Embrace a simple Market
principle charging interest
this is interesting what because they
can't charge or take interest uh that's
why you got to have Muslims you got to
have some good Muslims on the program
scholars in the dean I'm not talking
about myself I can hook you up people
who are more knowledgeable in this area
than myself I'm not I'm not a scholar in
Islam I just want to point that out but
I can hook you up with some good people
to get on the program but you got to
have but I'm inviting you Patrick to be
on the dean show so this is something
and I don't have to get into the
prohibition because they discuss it the
prohibition of it even in the the Bible
itself Usery is what you're reference
which was used to be outlawed in the
Christian Community
yes how Jews made all the money yes and
uh Jews find a workaround in the book of
Exodus it explicitly actually prohibits
it uh but the rabbis found a workaround
because they realized that flourishing
and prosperity actually yes comes with
the ability to charge interest right I'm
very pro-interest now the main
differences here there are some
fundamental differences between world
view of Muslims and Christians that I
think need to be ironed out but we got
so many things coming but if you want to
discuss the differences we get the
elephant I like to do that get it out of
the room that we can go ahead and focus
on many of the tissues issues but the
the first and most important thing is we
believe in the pure
monotheism let's go ahead and let the
Quran God Almighty the verbatim word of
God Almighty Allah speak for itself
another one of the differences is that
we believe in original goodness not
original sin that every child is born in
a fresh clean slate he's don't got a
criminal record a rap sheet none of
those things sin is not inherited I'd
give you example Patrick imagine Al
Capone you're very familiar with him and
other many of these gangsters that let's
say you were related somehow to Al
Capone a a distant family relative
member and next to you know they want to
come lock you up because some of the
crimes that Al Capone did that would
make any sense so we don't believe now
because what Adam did disobey God he
repented he he repented he was told how
to seek repentance it was a great lesson
for that but we don't believe because of
that sin that he did now we're we are
inheriting that sin so we don't believe
in that original
we don't believe in the original sin we
believe in the original goodness and the
original sin is the way you guys look at
we look at the original sin is the sin
of sin of arrogance is a sin of
arrogance it's a whole different
discussion but these are the differences
hey many people have many other
differences they live with their family
members and they can't get along with
certain things but they're still family
we are the greater family the the family
of humanity with the same father Adam so
I love the direction this is going let's
go ahead and keep it going we're living
in a place where the god of America has
replaced it with trans zealotry worship
of the self widespread narcissism and
kind of a globalist ideal yeah and so
the question is how do you then defeat
that thing and sometimes you have to
make a prudent step that you might not
be thrilled with to partner with a group
of people that you do not see eye to eye
on theologically or otherwise to build a
coalition to win here he talks about
again the importance of building
Coalition love Direction Patrick reasons
they tend to be a violent people too is
because their Prophet was a a very
violent person Christ was not oh major
mistake here major major
uh remember the Bible and Quran
experiment let's go ahead and take a
look at that here with all due respect
if two men are fighting and the wife of
one of them comes to rescue her husband
from his assailant you shall cut off her
hand look here is my virgin daughter
I'll bring them out to you now and you
can use them and do to them whatever you
wish but as for this man do no such
outrageous thing a woman should learn in
quietness and full submission I do not
permit a woman to teach or to assume
authority over a man she must be quiet
if someone has a stubborn and rebellious
son who does not obey his father and
mother then all the men of his town are
to Stone him to death you have a little
surprise for you all these heartwarming
passages that I read to you today
um they're actually
in the Bible are actually the Bible so
they say Muhammad killed people No Moses
also killed people but that was the
command of God to fight against those
who fight you so if the thief comes to
your house and smashes your wife and
your children and you hit him back they
say no no you are a criminal you hit
someone yeah but I hate in a context in
a reason I'm not going out killing
people or attacking someone's house but
someone attacked my house I have to
defend so if someone attacked Muhammad's
house if someone attacked this country
and killing innocent people as a leader
you gotta defend you're going to fight
back that's what it did if Jesus was the
king of his time I can assure you he
would have fought back and he would have
killed a few who were killing Innocents
now according to the Bible the
Christians believed Jesus Is God so
Moses killed people under whose command
and the God's command who is God
According to some Christians Jesus so
who commanded Moses to kill Jesus
but then the young man comes back and he
has a very a pretty good question that
he wants that be poses for Muslims to
think about it's impossible how you as a
Muslim could then say you believe in
what the Quran teaches and what Allah
commands of you right and also say it's
okay to teach this grooming perversion
Elon Omar Rashida Talib are sitting on
some I love hear how Patrick jumps in
he's talking about this makes no sense
words it makes no sense how we can't go
ahead and unite we got bigger fish to
fry stop being such a panzy and start
kind of like figuring out other people
and how we can create areas that we can
read and this is exactly right making
the evil Behavior seem normal we're
totally totally against that we're
talking about an area where the opposing
party
is doing evil things and it's making
evil Behavior seem normal and understand
with that let's just talk let's just
freaking talk because we keep acting
like everybody's perfect we can't unify
the group and that's why we've invited
you on the show we're extending our hand
we're extending invitation
we've made the connection we're waiting
to hit the balls in your court Patrick
we've heard from you you've heard from
us now we're waiting to hear back from
you so we can go ahead and look to make
this a historic reality now making
history this Vision you have I like it
many Muslims will also like it and we
can go ahead to spell many of these
myths we could talk about certain things
and we can hopefully make this a reality
because we there is a big agenda attack
on the children attack on our families
and we want to go ahead and protect our
children protect our families and we
will make a more powerful impact working
together you see that I see that most
Muslims see that so let's go ahead and
put these differences to the side we can
discuss that we can get the elephant out
of the room like some of these points
that I've touched upon
and we hope to hear from you and
inshallah God willing we can go ahead
and collaborate make a coalition of good
of good
thank you very much we'll see you next
time hope to hear from you soon Patrick
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum we've been told
yeah kill us all assalamualaikum
Brothers sister
Americans about Islam here's what they
said do you know anything about Islam No
do you know anything about Islam No
sadly do you know anything about Islam
uh not really do you know anything about
Islam
no
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that they're out
to kill us all that's what you've been
told that Muslims are out to kill you
all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit
thedineshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you